Ich kann sie flüstern hören: die Patente,
auf den Gedankengängen des Patentamts.
Sie erzählen Geschichten von Geistesblitzen,
Geniestreichen, Gehirnschmalz.
Von Ideen,
die die Welt veränderten,
Erfindungen,
die die Forschung revolutionierten.
Innovation als Inspiration –
für noch mehr Innovation.
Jede Idee, jede Erfindung
zieht ja weitere Erfindungen nach sich.
Denken Sie an den Übergang
von der Kutsche zum Automobil.
Jetzt sind wir dabei, da den nächsten
Innovationsschritt zu machen,
dass alternative Antriebe gesucht werden.
Und wir werden das erleben, wenn die
Elektroautos auf der Straße fahren –
mit Akku betrieben,
mit Brennstoffzelle betrieben –
dass diese Antriebe dann auch
weiterentwickelt werden
und so wieder
neue Erfindungen nach sich ziehen.
Aber nicht alle Patente
wurden zur Erfolgsgeschichte.
Mit manchen ließ sich kein Geld verdienen.
Andere überholte der Fortschritt.
Und wieder andere sollten nur
die Forschung der Konkurrenz blockieren.
Abgestempelt, alleingelassen,
liegen sie jetzt hier herum,
jahrzehntelang –
und seit sieben Jahren auch EP1625415.
Dieses Patent zum Beispiel
gehört der Deutschen Telekom.
Es geht dabei um ein Verfahren
zur Nutzung von Ortungsdaten.
Bestimmt ’ne gute Idee,
aber das Unternehmen nutzt sie nicht.
Heißt das jetzt,
dass das die Endstation ist für dieses Patent
oder bekommt es doch noch
’ne zweite Chance?
Es gibt Patente,
die brauchen diese zweite Chance –
oder vielleicht sogar
’ne dritte, ’ne vierte Chance.
Tim Pohlmann hat ein Herz
für ungenutzte Patente.
Klar, schließlich verdient er
mit ihnen sein Geld.
Sein Startup IPlytics nimmt alle Patente –
ob genutzt oder ungenutzt –,
speist sie in eine riesige Datenbank ein
und visualisiert sie.
Und die Kunden zahlen dafür.
Hier etwa die Patentanmeldungen von
Google, Microsoft und Apple im Vergleich.
Aber können die Unternehmen
so was nicht selbst machen?
Es geht immer mehr darum,
Patente zu verstehen.
Wir messen fast 100.000 neue
weltweite Patentanmeldungen im Monat
und die kann keiner mehr lesen.
Und dafür braucht man ’ne Software,
die diese Patente intelligent ausliest,
versteht, was inhaltlich in den Patenten steht,
und dann aber auch feststellen kann:
Ist das eigentlich relevant,
ist das wertvoll?
Das wollen vor allem Kunden
aus forschungsintensiven Branchen,
etwa IT-Unternehmen.
Mit Pohlmanns Datenanalyse
können sie die Erfindungen der Konkurrenz
im Blick behalten.
Und sie können die ungenutzten Patente
aus dem eigenen Haus wiederfinden.
Die können sie dann
entweder verkaufen oder lizensieren.
Gibt es also doch noch Hoffnung
für unser bislang ungenutztes Patent?
Wir finden es auf der Plattform von IPlytics.
Aufgrund dieser Informationen,
diesem wirklichen Inhalt des Patentes,
berechnet jetzt das Tool, ob es in dem
Bereich ähnliche andere Patente gibt,
ob sich da Unternehmen tummeln,
die in dem Bereich auch schon was machen,
weil das sind natürlich
jetzt meine potenziellen Käufer.
Unser Patent ist eine Technologie,
die Standortdaten auswertet
und daraus Vorhersagen trifft.
Das wäre auch was für Gamedesigner, die
wissen wollen, wo Spieler sich hinbewegen,
oder Automobilunternehmen,
die an selbstfahrenden Autos forschen
und Fahrtziele berechnen.
Das ist natürlich ’n positives Signal,
dass ich jetzt verstehen kann:
Okay, in einen [einer] der Branchen
könnte ich das Patent platzieren.
Ich könnte es lizensieren
an die relevanten Unternehmen
und könnte damit das Patent ...
dem Patent die zweite Chance geben,
es weiter zu kommerzialisieren.
Kommt doch noch groß raus.
Kommt doch noch groß raus –
vielleicht anders,
als der Erfinder sich das je vorgestellt hat.
Aber es bekommt vielleicht
’ne ganz andere Anwendung.
EP1625415 hofft also
auf eine zweite Chance.
Und die verspricht Tim Pohlmann auch
allen anderen ungenutzten Patenten.
Vielleicht finden sie also doch noch
aus dem Patentamt in unseren Alltag.
Eine gute Idee bleibt eine gute Idee.
Man muss sie nur festhalten.